it's protein
if you're trying to get big it's protein
if you're trying to get yolked
shrimp cheeks
i don't know try it
what's up guys my name is sola mariduena
and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
first snack up corn nuts let's do it
suave corn nuts are especially important
to me this is like the perfect gas
station snack right here and perfectly
sized too like you know sometimes when
you're snacking you're like [ __ ] i feel
bad i'm snacking whatever small look at
this how many calories
130 that's that is a lot for this small
thing but who cares who's counting my
favorite are these two right here the
ranch and the barbecue i don't think
this really tastes like ranch but it
still is delicious and a close second
place
is very delicious as well so these pop
them in your hand
hand full size and just throw it back
boom
drank me
boom
half right we're getting better next one
honest kids juice boxes now i know what
you're thinking
show low they have no flavor
and
to an extent you're right but here's
what i'll tell you my mother was one of
those moms growing up that was like we
gotta get the healthy version of
whatever they're still pretty delicious
though i haven't had one of these since
i was a kid so you're gonna get
a live reaction here of me trying the
appley ever after i mean if your snacks
aren't making puns then are they really
delicious snacks
nice i think as you get older
you don't need a capri-sun amount of
sugar honest kids is where it's at young
adults
next snack i already ate them all damn
it they're my crispy shrimp cheeks so
we're in new york right now i'm from los
angeles and this is in my backpack i
smuggled some some shrimp over here got
him from h mart shout out to hmart i'm a
big korean snack fan
so they do it right it feels like they
really found a way to utilize that skin
of the shrimp that you're not usually
supposed to eat and i don't know if
that's what it is but it's darn freaking
delicious
it's protein
if you're trying to get big it's protein
if you're trying to get yolked
shrimp cheeks
i don't know try it
hey yeah don't i wouldn't throw these
these are saucy boys all right complex
first we feast
this is a personal one for me okay
boom
pickles there was no applause but we'll
add it in post it's okay
um so this bag is already finished
actually but this brand right here kalyn
and kalyn pickles
i'm from la over at the grove they have
like a pickle stand
so i have a pickle plug now but dude i
must say the kosher dill chips are fire
but these honey mustard ones
oh man
are so
flippin good you would think oh show you
already finished all the pickles why are
you gonna bring it i was i wanted to
bring it so i could drink the juice here
with you guys here today i'll make sure
i get close to the mic too so you get a
little asmr action let's see
i might get cancelled for that but
oh man
you all about to have me licking my
fingers out here complex man
that was delicious
get yourself a pair of honeymoon and
they deliver and they deliver straight
to your door
i haven't done that yet but they do it
we're gonna move over to a drink this is
a personal right now show low favorite
that's the lemoncello lacroix
oh it's a little pickle
show low two years ago would have
laughed if you said he liked lacroix i
was a big anti-sparkling water guy but
now that i'm 20 i'm sophisticated this
is the best one the lemoncello one and
it's specifically because of the
aromatics
you sniff it
and this is 90 of the lacroix thing is
smelling what you're about to taste
obviously it's not going to be
freaking barks rootier you're not
getting it for the sugar
it's almost a little spicy what can i
say bottoms up
last one boom
the reese's peanut butter cups you gotta
save the sweetest for last
i'm not a big sweets guy and maybe
that's because my mom injected honest
kids juice into my veins but
this is an exception to that rule man
is there a perforation on this wrong
there we go
i was sweating there for a second huh
it's a i'm an actor
you know the deal
everyone's had one of these before
i used to be really into twix and
snickers
now
gotta eat my protein so i'm on the
peanut butter grind right now these are
delicious and
yeah sweet have one of them and call it
a day
bing
bada boom
[Music]
all right y'all
three burps later and 10 snacks later
i'm here i i handled it the gauntlet of
snacks if you're like hey i'd like to
check out more of this guy i have a
podcast with my best friend lonelobos
got a show that i'm blessed to be a part
of cobra kai season four is out the
karate madness is taking over the valley
once again all right thank you guys so
much for having me i'll see you guys
later
[Music]
you